[Music]
hi hope you're enjoying the conference
so far I wish I could be there with you
in person but this is the next best
thing and I'm excited to talk to you
today about accessibility and
coats-of-arms so if you're someone who
likes to follow along with slides while
the talk is going I did tweet them out
so you can go and look me up on Twitter
if you want to access those the
inspiration for this talk is basically
in software design and development often
we deal with complex problems and
lessons that can feel kind of novel and
new at first but a lot of times these
are problems that people have wrestled
with in some capacity for years or even
centuries so I thought it would be
interesting to take a look at design
specifically accessibility within the
historical lens of coats of arms so to
give you an idea where we're headed I'll
open by giving you some historical
context about coats of arms and what
they're for and where they come from for
the meat of this talk we'll look at the
lessons that we can learn from the
design of coats of arms and then we'll
talk about how to apply those lessons to
our work in software so a popular place
that you might have seen coats of arms
recently is in Game of Thrones so if
you're a fan of the series you might
recognize some of these symbols like the
Starks direwolf or in the middle Y of
the Lannister lion and these are symbols
or emblems that had special meaning to
those houses and were used to identify
people who belong to one of those houses
accessibility is kind of a big word and
especially in the last two to five years
it's been kind of a buzzword the this
talk is not meant to be an introduction
to accessibility there are college
courses and degrees and certificates on
that subject but just to kind of look at
best practices of accessibility within a
different historical lens and hopefully
you'll learn some interesting things and
kind of gained a new perspective so as
you probably know accessibility is about
more than just what something looks like
so more than just kind of using good
contrast and having a readable font it
means designing for people with motor
impairments by providing keyboard
accessible functions for everything that
you expect a user to do means accountant
dating screen readers for your website
things like that um so again this is not
intended to be a comprehensive
introduction to accessibility but I did
pull the top ten rules on accessibility
practices from the guide to the internet
for the EU and those are you don't worry
about memorizing these or anything I
just want to review them quickly
number one structure contents avoid
dependence on any one single sense
eyesight in particular help your users
avoid mistakes and if they make a
mistake show them how to correct it
avoid any unexpected behaviors like
flashing try and provide text
descriptions where possible make all of
the functions on your site or app
keyboard accessible avoid rushing your
users identify links and where they will
take you keep navigation UI consistent
and try and keep your experience
compatible across devices and browsers
so I both those down even more into just
three big roles which are structure
contents avoid dependence in any single
sense and avoid rushing your users or
pigeonholing them into any one action so
if you hear the term coats-of-arms you
might picture something that looks like
this that's not what it is the term
comes from if I were getting ready for
battle
and I were to put on my suit of armor
then I would usually put on an armorial
coat over that which would have a coat
of arms or essentially crest printed
onto it so the purpose of a coat of arms
is to be easily identifiable for the
house or country it represents and there
are several reasons why that's good it
enables you to record and embellish the
history of your nation in kind of a
visual format it was a way to identify
the dead sea that you could look at
their coat and see what house they
belong to it was a way to declare
military units so that if I were
traveling and saw a group of people I
could figure out if they were friendly
to my house based on their banner or
what they were wearing it was a means of
establishing pedigree if you could trace
back your coat several generations and
it was a way to pass down family honors
or symbols so I'm going to use the term
heraldry heraldry is defined as the
system by which coats of arms and other
armorial bearings are devised described
and regulated so it's kind of the
overarching concept I'm also going to
use the terms emblem and seal
interchangeably with coat of arms
they're considered subsets of coats of
arms so if I show you something that
looks more like a seal for a letter it's
also considered a coat of arms I wanted
to touch on rights abuse for coats of
arms because I think it's kind of
interesting so I pulled some facts from
some of the different countries that are
researched while I was preparing for
this talk
I'm Denmark any unlawful use of heraldic
arms is a criminal offence so if I'm
using a coat of arms that I don't have
the rights to I could technically be
charged criminally in Italy heraldic
matters were ruled outside the scope of
official law and similarly in South
Africa they said that all citizens can
wear arms as they please so kind of a
more flexible approach there in Scotland
coats of arms are considered heritable
property so up might inherit the family
farm and then also the family coat of
arms and in Ireland if you can trace
back your ancestry you can be granted
the rights to a coat of arms so I came
up with a basic timeline for some key
events in different regions surrounding
this concept so the earliest reference
that we have two coats of arms in
general as in 2000 BC an Egyptian
hieroglyphics and artwork they showed
rulers who wore particular emblems to
signify where they came from in the
first century in the Bible in the Book
of Numbers it references insignias of
the children of Israel which is also
considered a predecessor to this concept
and the 12th century heraldic designs
were in use by Western nobility by the
16th century they were strictly
regulated
Ireland and by the 17th through 19th
centuries they were widely used to
record family history so some
interesting events they're great so now
let's see what they look like so I tried
to pull a decent sample size of
different kinds of designs obviously
it's not totally comprehensive and I'm
gonna start with what you're probably
familiar with if you've seen crusts in a
tourist shop or something like that they
were probably from Scotland or Ireland
so often the ones that people are
familiar with are from Europe and
particularly in this top row you can see
some design commonalities with the two
figures on either side and the shield
and the for French and then um some type
of crown symbol and maybe a motto as
well so you can see certain similarities
and a lot of those Asian heraldry the
ones for China and South Korea look more
like seals in this case they're kind of
more round and bold the one representing
the Russian Empire you can see the
western influence it's got kind of some
similarities to some of the ones that we
saw in the previous slide and also point
out Japan in the bottom row those are
pictures of kamon which are emblems that
were used to represent houses and we'll
talk more about those later African
heraldry you can also see some Western
influence potentially as a result of
colonialism in particular for Nigeria
and Malawi Kenya and Somalia with the
two supporters on either side and the
central shield and then in the bottom
right you can see the coat of arms for
Sudan has an eagle featured prominently
which is a common trend for coats of
arms from the Middle East so these are
what some of the different heraldic
signs look like in the Middle East and
as you can see many of them feature this
Eagle which is called the Eagle of
Saladin and some kind of motto on the
bottom so it's kind of interesting to
see certain patterns within various
regions when it comes to their coats of
arms these are some of the symbols from
the Americas these ones tend to they I
think they all have some kind of
greenery which is kind of interesting
they also tend to be a little bit taller
than the others
I also found to be interesting and maybe
a little bit more color as well great so
again that's not obviously all of the
coats of arms there are but it's a
sampling so we were to think about what
makes a good coat of arms if we were to
create our own we would want it to be
easily identifiable potentially across a
battlefield to our enemies we might want
to incorporate symbols that had special
meaning to us are things that will look
impressive to someone else so those are
some things to keep in mind as we keep
going so this is again some of the
samples that I showed you and you can
see there's a lot of variety some of
them are extremely detailed and like
this one from Haiti which has a lot of
Manute details and some of them are more
bold like this one from China which is
an emblem that really kind of pops out
at you from among the rest so let's talk
about some of the things that are done
well in a lens of modern standards of
accessibility and again there's no right
and wrong because these are works of art
we're just choosing to look at them
within this particular framework so
generally these are pretty easily
distinguishable
so these are some heraldic symbols from
Germany and there are some similarities
like the use of the crown or the lion
and some of them but if two of them are
side by side I probably would be able to
tell them apart pretty easily which is
good there's generally good color
contrast this example is from Egypt and
it's got an object in the forefront
against a lighter background and then
it's got the red lining and I will point
out that if you had red-green color
blindness this wouldn't be ideal but it
does have some good contrast there's
evidence of clear themes specifically
within regions for a lot of these and a
good example is the Japanese kamon so
one example you can see that there's a
blossom in a lot of these symbols and
that symbolizes the renewal of life
often they're pretty recognizable even
if someone came from a different
background so in particular there's one
here that has a sword which is pretty
easy to interpret if you have an animal
with bared teeth that's also probably
pretty understandable so
a blanket rule but in general they have
recognizable elements for people who
come from different backgrounds so what
are some things that could have been
done better
according to modern standards of
accessibility this is an example
[Music]
nice herbal elements for people who come
from different backgrounds so what are
some things that could have been done
standpoint could provide a description
of what this looks like but obviously
it's intended to be a visual thing you
might think of the audible equivalent us
like a battle cry or something like that
as you're going into battle or maybe a
song readability is not always great so
this is a coat of arms from Portugal
that's been printed onto some fabric and
it's beautiful to look at but it's
really hard to make out the letters
along the bottom there so not super
readable some of them are very complex
like this one from Imperial Russia so if
I were to print this into a book and if
I were able to look at all of the
details like with a magnifying glass
then that could be interesting but if I
put it on to for example a coat of arms
a lot of this detail would probably get
lost great so now let's talk about what
lessons we can take away from some of
these designs on some of the problems
they faced so a big one is the meaning
and unintended meeting behind various
symbols so while I was researching this
talk I read a paper from some students
at Kansas State University on the
meaning of Chinese symbols on what they
mean in non Chinese cultures so one
example that they gave that I thought
was interesting was a fish which is a
symbol of good luck and joy in China and
is often used in business logos as a
result but if you were to apply this in
a more Western context a lot of times
those are only used in a logo for
something that's geared towards children
or a restaurant so you can see where
this could be confusing if I put a fish
into my coat of arms and I wanted it to
symbolize good luck and then someone
from a Western background saw it and
thought that my house was selling sushi
so even symbols like animal
that can seem clear to us often have
specific cultural connotations so the
international standard of organizations
provide some guidelines on symbols you
want to stay away in general from hand
gestures religious symbols and animals
which can be ambiguous culturally you
can use nature symbols in general like
Sun or rain or flowers graphics that are
officially recognized by it the ISO and
symbols that represent things like
equipment or transportation so something
like a truck or a hammer would be pretty
safe and AB star shapes like circles and
squares are also good choices as I
mentioned the International Organization
of standards and that's a body that was
established by the UN and is
headquartered in Geneva their purpose is
to develop high quality standards which
facilitate exchange of goods supports
growth promote innovation and protect
health safety and the environment so
you're probably familiar with some of
the icons that they've standardized
they're things that are used in safety
contexts or on road signs at airports
they can be things like hospital and no
diving sign and you can see by looking
at these that they're meant to be have a
universal meaning so you don't need to
speak a particular language to
understand these I think another case
study when it comes to the meaning of
symbols is interesting to look at the
kamon from Japan so I talked about
earlier the blossom is a symbol of the
renewal of life and if I came from
somewhere else I might be able to guess
that because plant life is pretty
frequently correlated with renewal of
life but it might be harder to
understand not having the right
background there are others like this
one in the top right is for diamonds
which might be unclear to me at first
glance so some of these symbols are
specific to a particular region another
important lesson that we can take away
from heraldic design is the importance
of establishing a framework for your
user so as you probably know we as human
beings are really good at recognizing
patterns and dealing with patterns and
you see this in UI design or good UI
design
with things like a menu which is pretty
consistent between websites that's very
helpful to me if I need to go to a
website and find something that the
navigation is consistent and an example
of this in heraldic design a lot of them
had a very strict format for a coat of
arms so this is a more Western one and
it shows the helmet and two supporters
and a battlecry or slogan along the top
so if I studied these and I was very
familiar with their Anatomy then I could
essentially read this and be able to
look at a coat of arms and say okay the
supporters of this house or this and
this is the motto and this is where
everything goes it's also good to
remember that as sick of you are as the
design your users are not going to be as
sick of it so this is called Jacob's log
the Internet user and basically if
you're looking at your own website for
maybe one hour couple hours every single
day even your most active users are only
spending a couple of minutes so in the
course of a month you can imagine that
you would have maybe 30 hours of time
spent looking at your website whereas
your user would only have maybe 15
minutes or so and as a result you might
be sick of the design and think that you
need a refresh but your user doesn't
have nearly the same exposure to it so
it's a good thing to keep in mind in
design in general I mean heavily related
they've done studies that find that
users actually like feeling pretty
exposed to a website so you might think
that they want a new and edgy experience
but in reality they probably like
feeling like they know exactly how your
website works another important lesson
that we can learn from heraldic design
is the importance of simplicity so this
is I think a good lesson from so my
name's Steve Krug and he referred to
users of the web as sharks who
essentially are going along and trying
to accomplish a specific thing and then
they accomplished that and have to keep
going and if they did stop then they'll
die they have to keep swimming so if you
can imagine your users when they go to
your website or not trying to like stop
and smell the roses they're trying to
accomplish one specific thing and
however you can
them do that will be good so this is an
example of where complexity won out this
is the 1915 coat of arms for the
austro-hungarian Empire and there's a
lot going on here they got into the
tradition of passing down history in a
coat of arms and you can see that there
are a bunch of flags and crowns and
symbols that have been jumbled together
here to the point that it's hard to get
any meaning from looking at it
so obviously it's very interesting and
if you know what's going on then I'm
sure it tells an interesting story but
maybe have been better to favor
simplicity depending on your purpose now
their important lesson that we can take
away eyes come related to complex text
flow so maybe you've had this experience
as an engineer where you get your page
laid out just right and everything looks
awesome and then you had one word and
all of a sudden I'm break and everything
has been changed and it looks horrible
so this is one of the examples of why
text flow is really hard to deal with in
particular if you're changing the
language as well that's an added
complication and in heraldic design
there's a similar corollary I have to
explain something first so if I were
Knight going into battle my right side
is called my dexter side and my left
side is called my sinister side so on a
coat of arms it looks like this the
user's right side is their dexter side
and their left side is their sinister
and the sinister side is considered more
feminine and the dexter side was
considered more masculine so the
maternal signs would often go on the
left
so when houses were initially combined
they would often just split them down
the middle and kind of put them together
and I'll show you why that doesn't
always work out great
these are two coats of arms one of which
is from Munich and one is from Frankfurt
and if I combine them it looks like this
so you lose a lot of the original design
so then we get this practice called
impalement which is a form of heraldic
combination or marshaling of two coats
of arms that's a little bit more nuanced
so this is an example of a composition
of different symbols that I think is
more effective on the left you see the
three blossoms here which is
representing
thing and then in the middle you have
the two lines which is another house and
then on the right you have the bugles
and the crosses so this is an example of
how you could combine several symbols in
a more thought-out approach that ends up
being more effective than just kind of
chopping them in the middle and sticking
them together and I think this is
heavily correlated to what it's like to
deal with text sometimes so there's not
really a clean way to just chop it often
you have to think very carefully about
composing elements on the bottom line
here is that it's really hard often it
can feel like this diary page with text
everywhere
and there's no like one-size-fits-all
solution specialization will be
necessary in your approach so to wrap up
if you take anything away from this talk
trying favor simplicity over complexity
it's a good idea to establish familiar
frameworks for your user and consider
the meaning that your symbols might have
particularly for people from a different
background so if you take anything away
those are the three things that I would
hope that you remember and again that I
did tweet out these slides thank you for
coming and I think we'll have some time
for questions
[Applause]
[Music]